[Musique]
le porte-avion Charles de Gaulle c'est
un outil de projection de projection de
puissance qui permet de combiner la
puissance aérienne d'un groupement
embarqué à la puissance navale d'un
bateau mobile capable de parcourir
jusqu'à 1000 km par jour
là le porte-avion Charles de Gaulle est
déployé en cas de mission Antarès et le
message qui est principalement planté
c'est le signalement que la France est
capable de déployer cette force
constituée par le groupe erwanaval pour
défendre le droit international pour
défendre la France ses intérêts et les
alliances
[Musique]
on a environ 300 tonnes dedans
réalimentaire ce qui nous permet d'avoir
en mission une autonomie de 45 jours
mais régulièrement à peu près tous les
10 jours on est ravitaillé à la mer par
un bâtiment de soutien ce qui nous
permet de récupérer des denrées fraîches
et de différents pays qui à proximité du
bateau lors de la mission
[Musique]
il y a la messe qui est dite au fait
deux fois par jour le matin le soir
trois fois le dimanche et puis c'est
aussi un endroit pour discuter avec les
marins les confesser puis ils peuvent
aussi venir c'est tout le temps ouvert
donc ils peuvent venir prier seul
[Musique]